during this time of social distancing we
all have experienced some type of
isolation during the pandemic
and it's been hard especially for our
kids but there's a church in henderson
that's making sure at least
one monumental experience for high
schoolers isn't taken away
we're talking about prom madison
kimbrough has more on this very special
event
all students have really lost a lot
because
of the covet 19 pandemic and
we're afraid that they're also going to
lose their prom saturday may 1st let the
dancing begin as mosaic church in
henderson is bringing back
a little bit of normalcy to juniors and
seniors across the valley
with their 2021 a night under the stars
prom
this is sort of like our last hurrah and
ccsc didn't put anything together for
that so mosaic church took up the
liberty of doing that themselves and
it's
really really great there will be a dj
decorations selfie photo booths and most
importantly students from all over the
valley
coming together to enjoy each other's
company something that has become so
foreign to all of us this past
year as a senior like i've never had a
real prom last year it was cancelled
and we haven't had like an experience
and i think it's just
important that they're hosting this and
that we actually get to experience that
before we get to graduate the event
starts at 4 and lasts until 11 pm
and due to social distancing and safety
guidelines mosaic church will be selling
tickets for a
one hour window allowing kids to come
for an hour and then leave with friends
to go to dinner or another activity
elsewhere this also helps keep the
capacity down and monitored
when i did prom it was such an event
about the problem it was a four-hour
deal where we went and we were there the
whole time with all of our friends
and we've found today that the culture
is much different it's ten dollars per
person and if students want to stay
longer they always have the option to
buy an extra ticket
madison kimbrough 8 news now
we have a link to buy tickets up on our
website and again a
night under the stars is open to all
juniors and seniors
across the valley